RESPOND.
BUT, FIRST, THERE IS A LOT
TO COVER IN TONIGHT'S
WE'RE GLAD YOU ARE WITH US.
NEWS RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
DOSSIER OF COURSE USED BY
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TO
OBTAIN FISA WARRANTS TO
SURVEIL MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THEN THE
PRESIDENT ELECT.
DOOR MEETINGS THIS WEEK
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVON NUNES THAT HE
SHOWING CLEAR ABUSE OF
ED HENRY IS ALSO REPORTING
THAT NUNES TOLD HIS
WITH THE ENTIRE HOUSE LATER
THIS MONTH.
NOW, THIS IS A MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT BUT, AS WE HAVE
NEEDS TO COME OUT AND IT
WILL BECAUSE I'M TELLING YOU
ANYTHING THIS COUNTRY HAS
EVER SEEN BEFORE.
THIS IS GOING TO REACH THE
VERY HIGHEST LEVELS OF YOUR
GOVERNMENT, INCLUDING THE
DOJ, THE FBI, THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, SARA CARTER
TONIGHT REPORTING AND WE
HAVE CONFIRMED WITH OUR
SOURCES THAT AS SOON AS NEXT
WEEK EXAMPLES OF SYSTEMIC
FISA ABUSE ALSO IN FACT BE
REVEALED AND UNBIASED
MAJOR STORY IT IS WORTHY OF
FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
BUT AS THE MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY SO ABUSIVELY BIASED
AND SO ANTI-TRUMP THAT THEY
CAN NO LONGER CARE ABOUT
SIMPLE, BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
TRUTH?
OUR CORN SUBSTITUTION, OUR
FREEDOMS, OUR LIBERTIES?
DOES THE MEDIA NOT CARE
ABOUT ANY OF THIS?
THE MEDIA AS WE HAVE BEEN
HISTORY AND SO RADICALLY
LEFT IN THEIR IDEOLOGY THAT
IN FACT SADLY TRUE FACTS
THEY DON'T GET THROUGH TO
THEM.
THE ONLY THING THAT SEEMS TO
MATTER IS DESTROYING AND
DELEGITIMIZING PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THAT HAS BEEN THEIR ONLY
OBJECTIVE FOR OVER A YEAR.
YOU SEE IT HAPPENING DAY
AFTER DAY, HOUR AFTER HOUR.
IT'S PRETTY DISGUSTING, IT'S
PATHETIC, IT'S A DISSERVICE,
IT'S WHY WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP ASKING THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS HERE ON THIS
PROGRAM AND WE WILL KEEP
GETTING INFORMATION THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, ALL OF YOU
DESERVE TO KNOW.
NOW, ALSO TONIGHT, THE
HIS FBI LAWYER MISTRESS LISA
PAGE OVER ANTI-TRUMP TEXT
MESSAGES.
THE PRESIDENT IS TELLING THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
WE'LL ESSENTIALLY GO BACK TO
THE INSURANCE POLICY, WHICH
AND WE WILL GET THIS GUY OUT
OF OFFICE?
I MEAN, THIS IS THE FBI WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I THINK THAT IS, YOU KNOW
THAT IS TREASON.
SEE, THAT'S TREASON RIGHT
THERE.
AND THEN THE PRESIDENT
ADDED:  THAT'S A TREASONOUS
ACT, WHAT HE TWEETED TO HIS
LOVER IS TREASONOUS.
HERE IS THE INSURANCE POLICY
TEXT MESSAGE PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS REFERRING TO.
THAT RISK.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE
POLICY IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
ON THIS SHOW WE BELIEVE WE
HAVEN'T CONFIRMED YET, THE
ANDY MENTIONED IN THAT TEXT
IS THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCAPE.
NOW THAT MESSAGE IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING OF THIS MASSIVE
SCANDAL.
STAY WITH US HERE.
IT GETS COMPLICATED.
NOW, STRZOK AND PAGE ALSO
CALLED TRUMP AN IDIOT.
A LOATHE SOME HUMAN AND SAID
F TRUMP AND CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS THEY ARE
WORKING TO DETERMINE IF
THESE TRUMP-HATING FBI
LOVERS WERE LEAKING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION TO THE PRESS
AFTER A NEW ROUND OF THEIR
9,000 MORE TO GO.
STRZOK ALSO SAT IN ON
HILLARY CLINTON'S FBI
INTERVIEW FOR THE EMAIL
EXONERATION LETTER BEFORE
OFF THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
THIS GUY'S CORRUPT TEN KILLS
TOUCH SEEMINGLY EVERYTHING
AND ALSO GENERAL FLYNN.
WHAT STRUCK HAS DONE HERE,
IT IS CROOKED, IT IS
SCANDALOUS AND EVEN FORMER
CLINTON STRATEGIST MARK PENN
SAID HE SHOULD BE FIRED.
THIS IS WHAT PENN SAID ON
>> I THINK THAT TWEET IS ONE
SOMEONE IN THE GOVERNMENT AT
EVERY LEVEL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW HE IS
STILL EMPLOYED BY THE FBI.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
HASN'T BEEN OPENED TO ALL OF
THIS.
TO ME, THAT IS HUGELY
DAMAGING TO CONFIDENCE IN
THE FBI.
THESE TWO FOLKS WERE HAVING
AN AFFAIR, USING OFFICIAL
GOVERNMENT CHANNELS FOR
THEIR PERSONAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
THAT ALONE WOULD HAVE MADE
HONEST FOR ONCE.
NOW, THERE ARE REPORTEDLY
10,000 TOTAL MESSAGES
BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE.
WE HAVE ONLY GOTTEN A
FRACTION OF THEM THAT
SCANDAL IS ONLY GOING TO GET
ABOUT PETER STRZOK TO THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL"
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALSO
TAKING AIM AT CONGRESSMAN
ADAM SCHIFF, THE RANKING
DEMOCRAT ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE BY SAYING, QUOTE:
HE LEFT MEETINGS WHERE
SAY A STORY ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON INSIDE THE
MEETINGS, IT'S PROBABLY
ILLEGAL WHAT HE IS DOING BUT
THE DEMOCRATS, WELL, THEY
KNOW IT'S A HOAX, AN EXCUSE
FOR THEM HAVING LOST THE
ELECTION.
NOW, WHILE IT'S UNCLEAR IF
SCHIFF HAS BEEN LEAKING, WE
KNOW FOR A FACT THAT ANOTHER
TOP RANKING DEMOCRAT HAS
BEEN LEAKING.
NOW CALLING SNEAKY SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN BECAUSE SHE
UNILATERALLY RELEASED THE
FUSION G.P.S. TESTIMONY
BEFORE CONGRESS AND TRUMP
TWEETED DEMOCRAT DIANNE
FEINSTEIN SHOULD NEVER HAVE
RELEASED SECRET COMMITTEE
TESTIMONY TO THE PUBLIC
WITHOUT AUTHORIZATION.
VERY DISRESPECTFUL TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
POSSIBLY ILLEGAL.
NOW, SHE BLAMED HER POOR
BET IN SCHOOL THE DOG ATE
HER HOMEWORK.
AND WHILE FEINSTEIN'S
ACTIONS ARE THREATENING TO
FUSION GPS AND THEIR FOUND
GLENN SIMPSON.
SIMPSON TESTIFIED HE NEVER
EVEN BOTHERED TO VERIFY WITH
THE FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HAD
ACTUALLY PUT IN THE RUSSIAN
SOURCED PHONY DOSSIER.
HE ALSO ADMITTED HE WAS
AGAINST TRUMP DURING THE
ELECTION.
CLEARLY SIMPSON WAS CLEARLY
HAPPY TO TAKE OVER
$10 MILLION FROM HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC SHE IS
RUNNING AND PUT THIS DOSSIER
TOGETHER THAT THEY THEN
TRIED TO USE TO INFLUENCE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
OH, RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA TO
INFLUENCE AN ELECTION.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY.
AND THEN A FISA WARRANT.
AND FINALLY TONIGHT,
JUDICIAL WATCH IS SCORING
ANOTHER MAJOR LEGAL VICTORY.
FEDERAL JUDGE IS ORDERING
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO RAMP
UP THE RELEASE OF HILLARY
WATCH, THE FBI DISCOVERED
72,000 PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
LAST YEAR THAT CLINTON
EITHER TRIED TO DELETE OR
DID NOT DISCLOSE.
YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS STUFF